thank you very much for coming out I'm
really excited to talk to you about a
topic that I find incredibly fascinating
which is generative artwork or writing
programs that generate artwork I think
it's a particularly interesting for
programmers because it sort of takes
that mindset that we all developed when
we learned how to program and it applies
it to an analysis of the visual world
around us and also to how we can create
visual artwork so to give you a little
bit of background about myself I'm a
have a traditional programming
background I have a degree in computer
science I worked for many years on an
open source distributed database called
Apache Cassandra some of you may have
used that and I apologize for any bugs
you hit you can blame them on me but
I've always really loved our work I've
always loved painting and drawing and so
a few years ago I decided to try and
take our work a little bit more
seriously and I looked around to figure
out what skills I could bring to bear on
my artwork and programming was sort of
the most obvious option for me so I kind
of stumbled my way into the world of
generative artwork I didn't even really
know that it existed at the time but I
got obsessed with it
and I kept making it over and over again
and a few years later now I've made
maybe 500 pieces of generative artwork
and I was lucky enough to switch over to
being an honor and artist full-time
earlier this year and as an aside I have
to say programming art work is way way
more fun than programming a database
it's there's uh there's no bug trackers
there's no code reviews nobody's
nitpicking my variable names or
whitespace zero tests I've literally
never written a test no documentation no
daily stand-ups I hate standing up in
the morning I would much rather just
program
so basically generative artwork it takes
all the the fun exciting parts of
programming and it doesn't have any of
the parts that you get paid for so
artists just don't get paid that's the
way it is but to give you an idea of the
sort of artwork that I make I'll just
show you a few images these are just a
couple of my favorites these are fairly
recent I think both of these are from
last year and a couple more from this
year so like most generative artists I'm
starting from sort of a blank canvas
here I'm not doing data visualization
there's no data set that I'm working
with here I'm not doing any sort of
image processing I'm just writing a
program that needs to draw something
interesting and I don't know I also
don't use any like Photoshop or
illustrator or anything like that it's
done exclusively through programming so
this is my my recent work but when I got
started I created the kind of work that
you might expect somebody with the
programming and computer science
background to create it was very
geometric very obviously mathematically
inspired and I felt like it needed
something else I felt like I could take
it a little bit further by introducing
more organic and natural elements to the
artwork and to me the best way to do
that was to go out and actually study
the natural world around me so I grabbed
my camera I went outside and I looked
for things that I found aesthetically
appealing but that I thought I could
maybe take a stab at reproducing with a
generative process and so I did a few
studies these are a couple of them
on the left this is of a field of kind
of dry dormant grass on the right it's a
wooden fence board and these are the
this is the generative artwork or output
not the original photograph and when I
did these studies I had to reproduce it
as carefully as I could trying to
capture all of the the patterns that I
could really discern and I learned a
couple of really really interesting
lessons from doing these studies the
first lesson that I learned was the
world is insanely mind-bogglingly
complex and detailed I mean any little
portion of it that she really looked at
closely and study has an immense amount
of detail on it it's pretty astounding
but the second lesson that I learned was
that despite all that detail and variety
my fairly simple generative programs
could actually do a reasonably good job
of reproducing what I saw and I thought
that was pretty interesting but I kind
of realized that the reason for that is
this the world itself is generative we
have laws of physics laws of chemistry
laws of biology and these are all rule
sets that organize that they govern how
the matter and the universe is organized
and anytime you have rule sets like that
patterns are naturally going to occur
but if you go out and you actually look
around in the natural world you don't
just see clean mathematical patterns or
obvious geometric organization you see a
big kind of tangled mess and that's
because there's another side to the
universe besides these rules we have we
have forces that we perceive as
randomness forces of entropy and chaotic
processes and so the world is really the
combination of these two things the sort
of structural elements and the sort of
random elements and that's where we get
a lot of interesting effects and that
puts generative artwork in a really
interesting place because computers are
really good at both sides of that on the
one hand
it's pretty obvious computers and
algorithms are great for describing
patterns and processes and organization
but interestingly on the other hand
computers are excellent at working with
randomness they sort of ironically allow
us to be very specific about the kinds
of randomness that we want any sort of
probability distribution that you can
think of you can express and you
basically get a free endless stream of
samples from that distribution so
generative artwork is basically the
perfect medium for exploring the
intersection of these two things and I
think that makes it a very interesting
and powerful medium and that's just one
of the reasons why I really love it I
wish I could talk about all the other
reasons but this is the one that I'm
going to focus on a little bit today so
when I did these studies I learned an
awful lot but I couldn't really directly
apply the patterns that I saw here to
artwork that I was creating it's hard to
work wooden fence for it into you know a
painting that you might want to create
so fortunately I kind of stumbled across
something else that was a lot more
useful to me I still love to draw on
paint all of the time and so I was
flipping through a sketchbook and
something really stood out to me it was
just a pretty simple abstract small
watercolour painting but I looked at the
watercolor and I was really astounded by
the the really interesting patterns that
you see in the shapes that that
developed there there's lots of
different textures and fine details and
variety in the behavior and I decided I
wanted to try to capture some of that
with the with the generative process and
I thought paint was especially nice to
try and do this with because it's very
abstract and very malleable right so I
could reshape it to sort of any purpose
that I want and it's very open to
interpretation
you know the viewer can see paint is
pretty much any object or even sort of
abstract emotional
qualities so paint makes sort of an
ideal thing to reuse in other generative
artwork so before I dive into my
generative model of how I tried to
recreate watercolor paint I want to make
something clear about my my goals here
so this is a sketch by Rembrandt and
when Rembrandt made this sketch he
ignored about 95% of what he saw what
Rembrandt was really excellent at was
picking out the 5% that was really
essential to the image and that really
defines it to him and so I'm going to do
something similar with watercolor my
goal is not to make something
photorealistic
or physically accurate simulation but
rather to try to extract the essence of
it that 5% it's a really characteristic
of it and makes it special and besides
kind of focusing on the essential parts
having a simple model has a couple of
other upsides the first is that I want
to be able to fully understand this
process or algorithm that I'm working
with and I want to be able to fit it all
in my working memory as an artist you
you really have to know every tool that
you work with from the top to the bottom
and it's a generative artist your
algorithms are your tools and so you
want to understand every aspect of them
the other upside to a really simple
model is that I'm not doing a sketch of
a single image I'm doing a sketch of an
entire process and so I want to be able
to adjust that process for different
uses I want to be able to tweak the
parameters and understand what they're
going to do I want to be able to tweak
the algorithm itself and so basically my
my process for modeling this watercolor
is pretty simple but I think it's I
think there's a lot of upsides to that
and it makes it easy to explain to you
guys as well so to look at some actual
watercolor paint this is pretty close to
what I'll be
basing my model on so I want you to look
pretty carefully at this for just a few
seconds when I looked at this they were
kind of three main characteristics that
stood out to me as being essential to
the watercolor and by the way the way I
created this was just i took a brush
with just water dampened the paper
loaded it with paints painted just a
small circle and waited for it to dry
so when i look at this there were kind
of three big characteristics that stood
out the first is that the paint didn't
stay where I painted the small circle it
sort of expanded outward and it deformed
a little bit it's not really a perfect
circle anymore the second is that pretty
obviously it doesn't have smooth curves
around the edges if y'all can see this
all the way in the back it has a rougher
texture it sort of reminds me of aerial
photographs of a shoreline where it has
sort of a fractal nature where parts of
it jut in and out but if you zoom in at
the smaller scales you see the same
patterns repeat even down to pretty
small scales and that's especially true
of some of the some other watercolor
examples I looked at and the last
characteristic that's pretty important
is that a lot of the edges are still
pretty soft here we see a lot of areas
where it blends smoothly from having a
lot of pigment all the way out to pure
paper and so those those kind of three
characteristics are what I focused on
with my model having the expansion and
distortion the kind of rough shoreline
like edges and then having a more smooth
blended transition so onto the actual
model I'm doing this with processing
which is an open source java graphics
library it's pretty low-level but I kind
of like it that way but like any good
programmer I hate writing Java so
I use a closure rapper called quill for
it and I highly recommend that so start
out with just this this very basic
polygon and we're gonna first work on
doing the sort of expansion and
deformation of the polygon and the model
for doing that it's pretty simple we're
going to walk around and deform one edge
at a time and we're going to just kind
of make it jut outward by some amounts
so we have to decide exactly how each
edge is going to jut out and there are
about well there are exactly three
variables as to how each edge is going
to shut out like that
the first is to kind of pick a starting
point in the middle of each edge and
this is where we're going to break the
existing edge and then kind of bend it
outward the next variable is is the
angle that we're going to bend that edge
outward at and the last variable is kind
of the magnitude of that that vector how
far out it's going to extend and when we
combine those we just basically get
something like this but we need to be
really careful about how we decide to do
this because it's going to have a really
big impact on the sort of effect that we
get and this is where that kind of
careful utilization of randomness is
really important so there are a couple
of main probability distributions that
usually come up when you're working on
artwork the first is the uniform
distribution which almost every
programmer has to have used I'm sure and
obviously you get sort of a uniform
probability of picking a number anywhere
within a range but in the natural world
you don't really see the uniform
distribution that often if ever you see
much more frequently in the Gaussian
distribution or the normal distribution
also called a bell curve and that's
where you specify a mean and an amount
of variance which controls how far away
from the mean you might draw your values
and so if you want to get natural
effects the way to go is to go with the
Gaussian distribution for things and so
that's exactly what I did here so for
each of these variables
I used a Gaussian distribution for this
one the mean is centered in the center
of the edge and I might pick values
further and further away from that with
decreasing probability for the angle the
mean is perpendicular but I might have
some variance away from being perfectly
perpendicular and for the magnitude it's
sort of a truncated distribution I only
want positive values because it never
shrinks in where it only goes outward
but other than that it's likely to only
expand out a short distance but
occasionally I might get parts that
stick out quite a bit
so with these nicely tuned distributions
if I run just one round of this on the
polygon I get something that looks a
little bit like this and this is a
pretty good start this gives us kind of
that growth in that weird
blobby distortion and so I think it's
time to move on to getting those kind of
rough details the fine tuning so what
I'm gonna do is kind of take advantage
of that fractal like nature where you
see the same patterns repeating at
smaller and smaller scales and I'm just
going to apply this function recursively
to the new polygon and the only thing I
have to do is make one small adjustment
when I pick the magnitude variable I
want to scale that by the length of the
edge so that as I'm dealing with smaller
and smaller edges it's sticking out less
and less each time so I run this
recursively six times and I suddenly get
a lot more detail and this looks pretty
good to me this reminds me of kind of
that that rough edge texture that I see
in a lot of the watercolor paint so the
next step is to start thinking about the
soft edges now we can make things blend
a little bit normally when I want to
create a sort of blend around a shape
I'll take the polygon and I'll stack a
bunch of train
parent layers layers that are nearly
transparent sorry low opacity and with
each one I'll just slightly shift them
around and that gives you a pretty good
effect but there's actually something
better that we already have on hand here
for doing that this function that we
just used to deform the polygon it's
already really good for making small
random changes to a polygon so what I'm
going to do is take advantage of that to
get differences in the layers so here's
the basic approach I take our original
starting polygon and I just run it
through three rounds of deformation so
this is six so with only three it'll be
somewhere in between not not all the way
fully detailed and then for each layer
and I'll do about 50 layers I'll start
from that that base polygon with three
rounds and I'll run it through three
more rounds to get all of the fine
details I draw the layer with really low
opacity move on to the next layer start
again from that same base polygon run it
through three different rounds of
deformation lay down a second layer so
each layer is going to have a lot of
really subtle differences but the on
sort of a macro scale all parts of the
shape are going to be the same so when
we do something like that we get our
nice soft texture here unfortunately
processing isn't perfect with really low
opacity layers so you still do see some
edges of polygons and that's just a fact
of life but there's one thing that I
want to try and improve about this and
that's the variety in terms of having
some parts of the edge be sharp and
other parts being a lot softer and a lot
more gradual blending transition this is
a this is pretty uniformly soft all the
way around so I want to exaggerate that
variation more so I came up with a
pretty basic approach for modeling this
and
like this for each edge in the original
polygon we go through and we assign a
level of variance and that's going to
control that magnitude variable how far
out that edge will jut and so we can
assign these sort of variance levels and
whenever we do break the edge and extend
it outward we create two child edges and
those inherit the variance level with
some small amount of variation so we're
going to keep that part of the blob sort
of consistent in terms of how much
variation it is and the higher variance
levels will be softer and the lower
variance levels will have a sharper edge
you can think of this as maybe being
kind of analogous to parts of the paper
being more wet than other parts the wet
parts to the paper transport the pigment
more readily the dry parts tend to stop
more abruptly so if we apply our
variance change we get something that
looks like this and this is a lot more
satisfying to me this down in the bottom
right side you can see we have some
really nice big soft transitions and we
still have a few areas that are a little
bit more abrupt and a little bit sharper
boundary so since I still have a pretty
good amount of time there's one other
detail that I snuck into this that I
want to talk about if you look closely
the center of this is slightly more
opaque than everything else I'm not sure
how visible that is on the projected
screen but that's something you'll see
in a lot of natural watercolor most of
the pigment stays in the center and so
you kind of see the remnants of the
original shape that you drew a little
bit so to get just a touch of that
effect I did something like this which
is instead of doing all 50 layers the
same way where I do three rounds on the
base polygon and then
three rounds for every single layer I
did something a little bit different for
the first third of the layers I only I
created the base polygon with only one
round of deformation so just a slight
change and then each layer got three on
top of that now I moved on to the second
third of the layers I added one more
round to the base polygon and then did
three for each layer on top of that and
then for the final third I did the full
three and three and so the first third
of the of the layers are going to be
closer to the center and as we keep
progressing we move further and further
out so it kind of concentrates the the
pigment so to speak in the center of our
blob and so if you look closely you see
that that kind of central effect so that
pretty much wraps up my model of
watercolor paint like I said I kept it
pretty simple but now I have a nice tool
at my disposal and I can reuse it in
sort of any way that I want to i've
almost created a little bit of a new
medium for myself as a generative artist
and that's kind of a cool aspect of
generative artwork is it's it's almost a
meta medium you sometimes with each
piece you're creating a new medium to
create work to create artwork within so
I'm just going to show you a couple of
examples of how I've I've used this this
was just one of the first really basic
pieces that I made with this technique
and I really was interested to see how
this responded in terms of different
areas of color blending and they don't
always blend really nicely especially if
the colors are very different the same
is true of paint but it's especially
kind of weird doing it through
processing so I had to be careful about
what colors I tried to blend and I did
one once a week that made the color
blending a little bit better which was
to use a texture mask for each of these
blobs and the texture mask you can
see it kind of looks like a grain on
here like a paper grain and that kind of
allows each blob to have parts that are
more transparent and more opaque so
layers underneath show through a little
bit better and the the other thing that
I did that that helped out the color
blending was instead of doing one blob
at a time all the way to completion then
the next blob all the way to completion
I sort of defined all of the blobs up
front and then did just the first layer
for every blob and then just the second
layer for every blob and then the third
and so on so they kind of the whole
thing sort of gets painted at the same
time and that helps to blend the colors
a little bit more naturally as well
eventually I wanted to make more
sophisticated pieces with this so these
are a couple of finished pieces of our
work that I made using this technique
and here I drifted a little bit further
away from that more natural watercolor
feel which is okay the the reason that I
did the watercolor study was not
necessarily to make fake watercolor
paintings but it was to kind of capture
that really interesting there's
interesting patterns and textures that I
saw in watercolor so these look a little
bit to me more like maybe fabric dye or
something like that but you still keep
all these really cool interesting
watercolor like textures in here I also
introduced a couple of decorative
elements introduced some masks on the
different layers of watercolor paint so
that's where you see some of the the
lighter lines where it allows lays below
it to show through but I want to talk
just a little bit about how you put
together a full generative piece it's it
does resemble a lot how I modeled the
watercolor process itself there's a lot
of carefully applied randomness in these
so if I ran the program that generated
this one a second time I would get a
pretty different results and that's by
design
it's a it's a careful balancing act when
you're working with randomness and
generative artwork you you want those
pleasant surprises that come from using
randomness you want it to do things that
maybe you couldn't think of yourself or
that you didn't expect or that are
really off-the-wall it's it's really
amazing for that type of exploration but
you don't want it to only do something
pleasant every two thousand images you
want it to do something pleasant every
maybe ten or twenty images so you try to
find this system of constraints around
the randomness or this sort of structure
that makes it more likely to produce
interesting things and determining
exactly what that structure is it's
different for every piece and is usually
the most challenging part of designing a
piece of artwork but it's what makes a
generative artwork a really fun way to
work for me so let me see how much time
I've got here okay so this is pretty
much everything that I have to say about
the watercolor process and about how
I've kind of applied it to a few pieces
of artwork and since we have some time
and people usually have no idea what
generative artwork is about I want to go
ahead and open it up for questions but
before I do thank you very much
everybody for having me out
okay so questions we're not going to use
a mic so just speak loudly I'll make
sure to repeat whatever you ask and I
think there was a question front so yeah
so the question was do I mainly work
with static images and processing or do
I take advantage of some of the
animation features of it I do
occasionally use animation but so far
I've only focused on static imagery
because it's it's already such a new
difficult thing to do
adding dimensions of of time just
complicates things infinitely I mean
literally you're adding an infinite
dimension to the work and it's hard
enough for me to make static to the
imagery and I feel like it'll be a long
time before I've sort of mastered that
in any sense and so I do play with
animation some but for now I'm focusing
on what I can learn just through static
2d geometry thank you another question
yes sure okay so the questions were how
do I save my work and can you see some
code so I saved my work through seeds
seeds for the random number generator I
think everybody in here probably knows
what a C it is so I won't explain that
but every time I update the program and
rerun it I use a new seed and I save the
seed as part of the file name and so
that way if I want to generate a much
larger image I can just rerun the
program with different size settings and
use the seed and that'll mostly work
there are some gotchas there but I won't
go into detail on those so other than
that I just save images is just TIFF
images which are nice for printing can
you see some code
you can see some code so on my website
which is nicely listed right there
I have blog posts I specifically have a
blog post about the watercolour approach
and it shows code in there I don't open
source all of my work that's kind of a
that's a long a topic that I won't get
into here but I'm happy to talk with
anybody about that afterwards today that
answer your questions
awesome yes sure so the question is have
I learned anything about water and the
sort of ways that water distorts things
and kind of the physical processes by
doing this this type of study so I I did
read a little bit about fluid dynamics
which kind of fell into the realm of
being too complicated for me they kind
of you know I talked about I want it to
be simple I want to understand
everything from the top to the bottom
and to do that with fluid dynamics would
take me a really long time and I didn't
I didn't care that much about having
physically accurate simulation on the
other hand it taught me something about
watercolor painting the actual process
of using watercolor paint when you
observe things with this very
process-oriented mindset this very
analytical mindset it's interesting you
learn a lot a lot more sort of in the
reverse direction as well so by doing
this sort of generative work my my
actual watercolor paintings have gotten
a lot better I think so I have learned a
lot but I haven't learned I can't say
that I've learned too much about fluid
dynamics yes have I looked at ink or
pencil at all I have looked at both
I like to that there are some
interesting textures and patterns that
you get out of ink and pencil kind of
graininess with ink you get variations
in the the line thickness but usually
what I study when I'm looking at ink and
pencil is more about the imperfections
and what happens when you draw something
by hand or or the way that if you're
trying to draw some pattern by hand
what what's actually going on in your
mind while you're doing that so if
you're trying to draw us a a circle over
and over again with a pen what what are
the rules that that are actually going
on in your minds about how you correct
the pen to keep it close to the circle
and can you recreate that in a
processing and can you capture that kind
of mixture of randomness and intent and
so I find that part of it a little bit
more interesting than the specific
textures of pen and pencil but I would
encourage you to investigate the pen and
pencil yourself yes yes question there
how long do the paintings take to render
anywhere from a tenth of a second to
maybe one or two minutes at the high end
that depends a lot on the polygon count
and the line count the watercolor stuff
is actually infuriatingly slow because
these polygons they end up with a lot of
edges and especially like this one I
think was close to a minute I don't like
I don't like waiting quite that long for
pieces to to render I try to keep things
in the several seconds range instead if
I can this gentleman right here one do I
think my work will pass a Turing test
yeah I mean translating the Turing test
to artwork is I mean it is created by
human right so I hope I'm passing the
Turing test in that aspect
but I do very frequently have people
think that I've done this worked by
hands not maybe not as much with the
wallet watercolour although people do
say that but especially with line
drawings by hand so let me see if I can
go back to I think it was this one yeah
so like the image on the left a lot of
people even looking at a really large
print up close they asked me how long
did it take you to draw this by hand and
I told them I would be insane if I tried
to do this by hand but that's what's
cool that's what that's what I love
about trying to capture that that kind
of human warmth in the work and that's
what all that little carefully placed
randomness gives you is that that warm
natural feeling so even though this is
all triangles ostensibly it has a much
more natural warm feeling and so people
do mistake it for being drawn by hand
I'm pretty often let me see how much
time I've got yeah there's a break after
this to you so we've got plenty of time
question back there yes
the question is the normal distribution
is awesome and it's a good thing that
I'm using it but have I thought about
using other distributions so the only
other one that I tend to use is boy you
put me on the spot I'm blanking on the
name of it it's the one where almost all
of your values are very close to yeah
like a Poisson distribution exactly yeah
man that's a that's great audience
so yeah I you know I did take a
probability class in in University and I
remember I loved it and I remember there
being a lot of cool distributions but
that and the the triangle distribution
has come in handy in a couple places but
other than that normal distribution
works for me about 95 percent of the
time yeah I'll come back to you next
time sorry yeah perfect question yeah
who are some other other artists that
you can take a look at if you're
interested so boy there's a lot of them
so so probably the biggest name in
generative art work and one of the
authors of processing is a gentleman by
the name of Kay serious reas and he's
actually been pretty successful in the
actual art world and convincing people
to pay a lot of money for his art work
some of my favorites
there's a gentleman in Australia named
Jonathan McCabe who does his works on
Flickr primarily but it's he uses a lot
of cellular automata work that kind of
recreates a lot of interesting
biological patterns I would suggest
looking at there's actually a generative
art subreddit that I'm a moderator on
our generative
and that actually has a really good
sampling of lots of generative artists
so if you want to see a good variety
that's that's one spot that's actually
one of the better collections on the
Internet of generative artwork yes your
turn so the question is obviously it's
hard to estimate because there's a lot
of code reuse in my work which is
definitely true but roughly how long
does it take me to create a piece of
artwork from from sort of the start of
the concept until the finished piece
there's there's a lot of variation in
that my typical range is probably five
to ten hours sometimes I get lucky and
something good comes out in one hour
sometimes it's a real grind and I work
on it for 20 or 30 hours and that's
especially true if if I'm doing
something that's like a commission where
I'm working back and forth with a client
on a piece but generative art works
really interesting in that way because
sometimes these really elaborate
detailed pieces just come together
really quickly and it only takes a few
lines of code and so it's it's all over
the place
whereas with something like a painting
you have a much more predictable amount
of time I think that that you're going
to spend on a piece so I love how fast I
can work with generative artwork most of
the time all the way in the back yeah
sure so the question is have I
considered pairing audio synthesis with
the visual aspect of generative artwork
I've considered it but for the same
reason that I don't do animation I don't
do that it's it makes it really
difficult and I'm not quite there yet
and I also lose some of the control that
I like I like having the control that
having a sort of no input program gives
you I think there's a question over here
have I thought about importing
randomness from nature
I have not what's an example that you
might think of ah now I'm curious yeah
okay so like sampling a photograph as a
source of randomness I have not thought
about that that might be an interesting
way to get some really unique
probability distributions though so
that's a cool idea yes right beside you
yeah
yeah have I considered providing my own
randomness through some sort of input
like maybe keyboard or Wii mode or or
whatever I thought about it maybe just
briefly but there weren't any huge
advantages that stuck out to me I don't
want to make things kind of interactive
just for the sake of making people feel
like they've had a meaningful input a
lot of work that does that it feels kind
of cheap to me and I'd rather that they
just made something cool without me
waving a thing around that's how I feel
yeah the question was do I agree with
mcclee generate all the shapes or do I
use SVG to import anything the answer is
that I algorithmically generate and
almost all my pieces 100% of its I don't
I don't import any sort of geometric
shapes the closest thing that I can
think of is occasionally I will
integrate hand drawn elements so digital
painting elements so if I want to do
something like a generative portrait
then I will make I will I will integrate
hand drawn elements in it in various
ways yes have I experimented with
working in 3d but projecting it back
into 2d so anytime you look at a 3d
image on your screen it is naturally
projected back in the 2d so I'm not sure
about that part of it but yeah yeah yeah
I do I do all my computations in 2d I
don't do any three-dimensional geometry
or sort of perspective or anything like
that
sometimes I allude to a
three-dimensional elements like this one
on the right
you might perceive some depth there but
no all of my math is basically
two-dimensional yes
yeah so the question is do I have the
concept ready to go upfront or do I kind
of work more iteratively and and the
answer is that most often I'm working
very iteratively and it's very
exploratory and that's one of the
strengths of the medium is that it's so
mutable you don't have to figure out
everything up front and and any painter
will tell you even if you try to plan
out a whole painting and you do studies
and sketches when you go to paint the
final painting things don't work out and
you have to adjust things on the fly so
it's it's already difficult to plan
things out perfectly and and so I find
that I make the best work when I know
very little upfront about what I'm going
to do and I just try to be open to see
new things come out of the artwork so
time for one more question who has the
better question which this guy looks
pretty confident I'll talk to you
afterwards yes that's a question I like
this I knew I went with this guy for a
reason the question is if you purchase
one of my works do you get the source
code to you the answer is yes I provide
a printout of the source code to the
works along with the prints and all of
my prints are single audition works I
don't do multi edition prints of
anything thanks you all very much for
all the great questions really enjoyed
it